is finally the time I'm here 48 hours we
have completed these renders they're
each their own little satisfying chunk
of musical goodness with musical
mischief and a couple slap cheeks what
you'll see
satisfaction comes in many forms as we
all know the way we like to do it here
though is with the render
I have always focused on sound design on
the satisfying render it's the ASMR
aspect of the sound
but music on the other hand is that
satisfying it is do you know what's
satisfying the tempo is consistent we
know what to expect and when it lands as
we desire it makes us feel today we're
going to take more than just a render
we're taking music audio and combining
that with the satisfying physics of our
beloved records I think we have our work
cut out for us yeah that's fine
Dynamic buds I know what you're thinking
Matt and I we made a mobile game app and
in it I created the first and maybe only
ever Dynamic but slash pregnancy system
okay this is a way to inflate butts like
that so my idea right look let him just
Zelda it's a beautiful game the lore is
beautiful the characters are so adorable
I'm gonna take one of the characters
okay from Zelda look at him imagine him
with some plump old cheeks plump cheeks
you don't want to like smack them you
know but you want to like smack them and
those cheeks are going to elicit the
sound of a song from Ocarina of Time
should I not do this
don't judge you'll look back on this
with regret I definitely won't
I won't regret this God
actually Skyrim
that's part of the Caribbean right that
my rendition of it definitely sounded
like that didn't it so Victor demartron
he makes Incredible renders of these
like little physics Sims of marbles
falling down these little xylophone
pieces
[Music]
how cool is that like his style of
videos is literally kind of what's
inspiring this whole render challenge
but I don't want to do exactly the same
thing so I have the Skyrim theme and I
want to do it some way like this where
it's like kind of physics based I could
maybe turn a Dragonborn helmet into some
sort of like hand pan
see this is where I'm worried because
I'm going head to head with not only
Jordan
but the Maestro of Music himself
samjiman has made multiple albums of
Music Sam's already Brewing something
incredible I know it
goes oh
yeah Rain Rain Go Away That's the Song
Wait really yeah I want to do something
that's thematically relevant to a song
what should we what should we do here
and I was joking around in our
brainstorm session about like car
Springs
to the beat or something like that and
then I was like Wow Let's do just car
accidents car crashes what better way to
motivate that than a rainy day in La
that's what I'm doing here it's a sunny
road that constantly starts getting
rained on and each time it rains on it
the car is all slip out of control and
they hit each other to the beat you know
you want to make sure it feels totally
natural and then it just all naturally
goes beep beep beep beep beep what's up
y'all I'm the resident production cook
here at Corridor whether they're making
satisfying renders on a shoot or on a
travel production I gotta make sure the
crew is fed so I'm very excited to
introduce today's sponsor cook Unity so
our cook Unity shipment just arrived and
there's some awesome meals in here so
while I get those heated up I'm gonna
tell you a little bit more about them
cook Unity is the first shift to
Consumer platform delivering freshly
prepared pre-selected meals right to
your door weekly music deliver fully
cooked so all you have to do is heat
them up there's no more cleaning no more
meal prepping no more shopping and
cooking can be fun sometimes but also
life totally gets in the way so my
favorite part about cooking is the
convenience without sacrificing quality
Chef's cooking meals with real
ingredients nothing artificial with
humanly raised meat and organic
ingredients whenever possible the chefs
offer a wide range of meals with over
seven different dietary preferences plus
the subscription is super flexible so
you can pause skip weeks or even cancel
at any time no penalty
[Music]
oh wow well Esther Troy provided us with
the bulgogi bibimbap today
[Music]
I think Jordan Allen's gonna like this
one so all the meals are cooked the last
step is just to deliver them and Chow
Down But first if you want to give it a
shot go to cooking.com quarter crew and
use the code quarter crew 50 at checkout
and get 50 off your first order no
reason why not to super easy super tasty
meals now let's eat how do you feel sir
oh I'm hungry brother oh my gosh I love
the knife though cut my pickles I always
cut my pre-cut pickles
the pickle that I cut with my knife take
the ride of a bulgogi lifetime baby
foreign
[Music]
we have a scene
the guys are going to love
look at this hold on he's so cute oh you
big Zelda fans you know the kickwees I
haven't played any of them
but the kick way
I can take this kind of cute character
and make him way cuter
oh jeez dude look at this
it's a cakeweed dude
so the way that this is actually working
is I'm taking the geometry of the cake
way I'm posing it as I need it and then
I'm selecting certain portions of it and
tethering it essentially with the booty
I also inflated it with internal
pressure so there's this this Force
that's trying to make it blow up
so in the game you get different weapons
from different areas and one of the
things you can do is you can kill the
cob ones and you can use their arms as a
sword so these are bakoblin arms so
every single arm here is a specific note
in the Lost Woods song from Ocarina time
every single hand has a designated note
that it is triggering on a designated
frame so the timing of that is very
important these are models that I found
online I rigged them with a couple bones
and then very simply just rotated the
root bone here to slap over three frames
that's it it's a super rigid animation
but in Houdini there's this really cool
tool called secondary motion and what
that does is it looks at all the bones
that are children of the main bone that
you're animating and will delay motion
across the entire thing so you get
something way nicer look at this way
nicer way more natural with a slap more
of a whip in this case here's the real
caveat to this I'm not used to cute
right I'm used to weird that's like
that's my Baseline I'm comfy there how
jiggly
Shoulda but be to be cute and not weird
this is something I had to trial and
error a little bit I'm really trying to
be true to the game like this I want
this to be a one-to-one experience I
want you to open this render watch it
and go gosh it's like I'm playing the
game found this little pack of low poly
cars on sketchfab at 10 bucks boom so
I'm carefully orchestrating these
physics simulations it requires a lot of
iterations because I set them up and I
get them to impact each other but to get
them all to kind of create a chain
reaction I gotta do it a few dozen times
beep
beep beep beep
it's all this one's almost done there's
no Hannah animation here I'm trying to
keep this all simulated with physics
it's a little hard because you have to
kind of constantly reset and clear your
simulation fine tune everything and try
and get them all to hit at the right
time on the beat so but I think I'm
starting to get the swing of it
no no I just gotta kind of put my nose
to the grindstone here and make art
it's finally the time we have completed
these renders they're each their own
little satisfying chunk of musical
goodness I haven't seen either
renders yet so I don't know what to
expect
um but I'm pretty happy with my render I
say we start with mine
this takes me back I've played this game
I've had like 15 new games on this
freaking hundreds of hours poured in and
I could watch this for quite a while I
mean visually it's really really nice oh
thank you and I could watch it all day
I'm satisfied by a lot of things going
on here render quality materials
lighting like just your visual Fidelity
I'm not entirely satisfied with how the
music and the visuals tied together I
think that's really the big thing for me
I I think we definitely underestimated
the challenge involved with making this
musical because hitting certain notes is
a whole extra level of
gee that I didn't exactly anticipate I I
kind of went by the books on this I took
the assignment very seriously I did not
go outside the box good so with that I
present to you my uh
satisfying one
[Music]
oh
I get the music now
thank you
do their hazards go on when they get hit
yeah that's so fun I love it and I love
how you have the Breakaway side pieces
as well I like the way that this is
entirely driven by physics yeah so no
hand animation that's the hard part
that's great did you pitch shift actual
honking horns took a horns down and I
dragged it into a window and I did the
Melody and I hit export oh did you play
the key
to the key so I don't need to like pitch
shifter to do anything fancy like just
does it all for me dang I wish
I wanted a tune
those tears there's so many
[Music]
why do the butts have nipples
laughs
[Music]
I love this episode of Zelda dude
but why
this is I'm using fish it doesn't even
matter does it
you're using physics
this is real real world physics wow okay
the Melody's like slightly off it's like
I'm just saying if I never played the
Zelda games I would say this is like a
perfect Zelda render
the plump butt cheeks yes dude yeah we
all know that part the way those booties
just
form
good job with that thank you
maybe you have succeeded because you
just can't stop watching this there is
something kind of satisfying about this
though
if we do it is it do you feel like it's
cute or weird why not
I'll take that man
I'll take that sometimes satisfaction
comes in mysterious ways sometimes it
comes sliding down the street sometimes
it just slaps you right across the
cheeks yeah for anyone in the comments
who's played these games uh can you do
me a favor and just write the lore in
the comments as to what is actually
going on with these kickways but if we
could do it for Sam maybe he gets some
peace in his bones you know it could it
could Eternal massage it's just that you
said this was gonna be a Zelda render
but you know what that's all right baby
that's all right
he's feeling things man
this is Canon I think